on this episode I have a guest you ask
questions and I answer them this is the
ask Gary be shut up
yeah
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 72 of the askgaryvee
show
or should I say the ask Gary and Casey
show that's right for the first time
ever you know 72 is such a symbolic
number that I figured we would use that
to break out the multiple person
askgaryvee show
so case thanks for being the first
person however here happy to be here
wanted some questions why don't you tell
the vaynernation a little bit you know
let's call it a 72 second version of who
you are for the few that don't know and
then we'll just get right into the
questions okay Who I am for those who
don't know I live in New York City I
work in New York City this is one of my
offices one of my companies I'm mostly
known as a filmmaker I love making
movies on the internet but I also do a
lot of advertising work for companies
like j.crew and Nike and mercedes-benz
and I also work with other companies
like the New York Times making films for
them how's that was that good the father
of two I like to skateboard and yeah
that's I mean the bottom line is let's
put it this way d-roc is so excited
right now that I can barely deal with
the tension in the room just try to hold
the camera so and so you know please go
down the rabbit hole that is Casey he's
an incredible storyteller and for me a
lot of you know that I love talking
about market in the year that you
actually live in this is a filmmaker
storyteller in the year that we actually
live in while a lot of his
contemporaries and people of his talent
have not recognized the world we
actually live in you've been one of the
few that has in my opinion and for
whatever that's worth so that's how I
see it I'll take it care cool let's get
into the show
Joe asks what advice would you give a
high school senior in America trying to
decide whether to go to college and if
so which one drama to let Casey answer
this first just cuz I think it'd be fun
to have you start off this ya know I've
got a strong feeling about further
education which is that I think in life
you should only be doing two things ever
and one is like discovering what your
passion is and then two is realizing it
so Joe if you know what you wanted
you and you are convicted that's where
you want to be in life and that
trajectory does not necessitate a
college education
then skip it chances are you don't know
what you want to do otherwise you
wouldn't be asking us this question and
if you don't know what you want to do
your responsibility is to figure that
out
in college is one of the best places one
of the best atmospheres environments you
can be in to figure out what your
calling is in life to figure out what
your passion is what your purpose is so
I'm going to jump in here as the cars
are racing outside and say this I agree
with the ton of what Casey said I'll
also add that if you're taking $200,000
in debt to find your passion that might
be a practical kind of by the way debt
that you can't even declared bankruptcy
against which complete I mean I can't
even I'm suffocated by the the game the
ache a racket that is student loans and
today in today's environment things that
you and I didn't have there are other
places where young people congregate and
pound into each other and the
serendipity of finding those mentors or
contemporaries that allow people to
discover so look I think one thing for
sure it's fun entrepreneur I look at you
as an entrepreneurial artist I but I
look at you way more artistic than I may
so call it entrepreneur artist boy
there's a lot of rationale in a 2015
world where college is not the right
answer and I think you know what's
really been unique to me Joe is I'm
adding your weird answer I actually find
that there's an enormous amount of kids
and I'm spending a lot of time on this
topic since I was a [ __ ] student and
have made something of myself that a lot
of kids are still just going to college
just making that decision on not wanting
to disappoint their parents and that to
me is maybe those fascinating thing
going on is that father of five and a
two-year-old living on the Upper East
Side with elite private schools where
I'm paying college tuition for
kindergarten already it's been funny to
me because I'm really poking and
prodding the parents that are my new
contemporaries to see how much pressure
and they have not switched yet the
reason I keep talking about college in a
world where a lot of my friends talk
about its demise as more of a 20-year
thing than a 10-year thing is because I
still think parents of my generation
still value it too much for their own
self-esteem they want to say their kids
went to Stanford and Harvard and things
of that nature so look you've got to
make your own decision but I'm with you
like
discovering it and then I mean curious
now I'm like mixing up the show what do
you think about this based on your
answer because that your answer is my
answer and there's one other there's one
other part that I'm trying to figure out
I'm a big fan of practicality I think
you and I got lucky that not only were
were we able to figure out our passion
but we actually had some level of talent
within it
there's a lot of people a lot of the
people that go and try out for American
Idol or the wannabe NBA players what's
your point of view on Joe figuring out
his passion is to paint but he sucks
[ __ ] at it well you know I think that
anyone's life your world always shrinks
and expands in proportion to your
willingness to take risk or try new
things and that's why I think that like
an academic environment is a great place
for trying new things and experimenting
with new things so if your passion is
painting and you're terrible painter
then maybe being an environment like
college will open your eyes to something
like graphic design which doesn't
involve a paintbrush yep but you can
make a great living at it and you're
realizing an artistic passion that is
certainly in line with painting and you
think do you think that then one needs
to be challenged to make sure they go
into the funnel of college to recognize
they're not there to check those boxes
because the way you play the game
actually has as much to do with the game
right if you hack college in the way
that you're talking about it you know
now you're starting to think about you
know course selection you're talking
about the kind of group of friends that
you're spending time with you know I
mean I think college is can be a total
waste of time and money if not
approached carefully and I think a lot
of kids today go there for a lot of the
wrong reasons like what you're
suggesting and certainly if there are
better other opportunities that feel
better to you then College I think now
today those opportunities are more proud
are are as practical as an academic
education I can tell you that a big
falsehood is that by going to college
you will get something else you will
find success and one thing that's
becoming more and more true especially
as technology is opening up all new
means of
a transmission of information is that is
that if there were a defined path to
success especially in any sort of
creative endeavor everyone would just
follow that define path there is no
defined path and college can be a great
way to help you find one of those paths
but it is certainly not the only way and
it's certainly not a guarantee that
you'll find that trajectory yep let's
move on
onder's asks how do you keep aim on your
goals and separate yourself from the
demands of the external world Roger I'll
take this one first
uh you know I don't know what to tell
you other than it's unbelievable for me
how much the external world has not
factored into my decision making I've
talked about if you've been watching the
show long enough that first F on a on a
test in fourth grade and literally
making that transition to I'm gonna
fight the market and I've been fighting
the market my whole life I think for me
it was the level of self-esteem that my
mom instilled in me plus some level of
my own DNA I think that's the friction
at hand heck a lot of the themes of our
last question we're on this right like
what does the market want you to do
whether that's your parents or society
versus what you want to do for me it has
a lot to do with intestinal fortitude a
Gorilla Monsoon WWF reference uh you
know I think I think its surrounding
yourself with people that give you
permission to take that risk that to me
is the most practical version of what
I'm giving you other than you got to be
born with it it's finding those
like-minded people who are who are
taking those similar risks and and give
you through their own actions a little
more um or if you're amazingly lucky to
have that parental or mentor
infrastructure above you that created
that context case I think focus is
everything I think that you can do ten
things poorly or one thing well and say
no is something that I only learned late
in my career don't suck at it I still
suck at it right now say no is so hard
but the truth is like we're surrounded
by leeches blood suckers and vampires
and those are people that want to take
take take and they don't give back and
learning to say no to those
we're going to say no to all those
distractions is the only way to get
anywhere because time is finite life is
short quickly you find things that are
in life that are really incredible like
family things that you love things that
you're passionate about that might that
might distract you in a positive way
from from your career focus so you have
to learn to shed everything out I'm
gonna throw a little bit of a curveball
I I get so much happiness out of doing
things for people who would be cool you
know categorize as the way you just
broke it down because I'm the weird gear
inside of me that has zero expectation
for the return on someone's selfishness
I know that's a little bit of a mouthful
but it's just it's probably why I'm so
ridiculously happy I'm I have such
little expectation for the return it
makes me happy to do the give I sit in
front of you knowing I will accomplish
less in my career and a mass less wealth
and a lot of other things less time with
my family which is my number one because
I get so much happiness out of some of
those actions so I would tell you if
you're in a rare group like myself make
sure you recognize in a world where
people tell you that you're a sucker for
doing and things of that nature
you still got to make yourself happy but
I will tell you I'm Way happier than I
was five years ago because I have grown
in my no meter moving a ton hasn't gone
a zero and I think a lot of people
closed themselves out of serendipity by
saying no too much right and I think we
probably both benefited through our
years of of the yes when it didn't make
sense on paper but I'm with you man then
I mean I made a video a long time ago
the yes virus it's like the sickness of
just saying yes all the time and it's a
tough one yeah they're big movies
everybody's just say yes like I believe
in saying yes I believe in embracing
risk and embracing chance and all you
can say no more as you get older I just
think it's a learning curve a very steep
learning curve to understand when note
is appropriate when yes is appropriate
and until you learn that you default to
yes it's a really really or know my dad
defaults to no I think you and I like we
have some similarities that makes like I
think there's a lot of people there that
default to no I think there's a lot of
people at the for my dad's opening words
and hate that no
like here I was gonna say how was your
day you know like knows not a property
like I know a lot of people that default
into no I think we happen to be
surrounded by a lot of people that
default into yes yes but I think you
know being you know what actually quick
little side question of the day
give me a are you a default yes or no
person I'm just curious from my own kind
of like polling India
move it along CJ asks how is having a
family changed your long-term view of
work and what does retirement mean to
you CJ asked a good question I'll let
you go because I know you're new father
of a second yeah so what does family
have to do with work I think family is
the ultimate cheat and what I mean by
that is I had a kid around 16 I've
always had a family since I was an adult
my entire adult life I've had a family
and it gives you a reason to do all this
work and that downtrodden feeling you
can have which is like why am I doing
this why am i working another night till
3:00 in the morning when you have family
for me it gives me my purpose my reason
for doing everything I do is my family
part to retirement retirements my
biggest fear retirement is what people
do when they wait to die my grandmother
was a tap dancer and she had a tap in
school and she taught tap every day of
her life and she taught tap on a Friday
and she died on a Monday when she was 92
that's my fantasy I want to work until
the last minute I want to be working in
my hospital bed as I'm dying so that's
how I feel about retirement I'll start
with retirement I meant you know in the
complete same camp you know that is my
nightmare I want to die on Monday on the
Monday that I'm working I didn't need
those two days in between you know I I'm
with you I think we're talking you know
look I will say this there's one weird
retirement fantasy I have which is to be
an old man sitting at the racetrack
having some nickname like one-eyed Gary
and like betting on the ponies I do like
the notion of the ponies as an old man
so there's a little bit of that you know
the family work work life balance whole
thing I think is completely
counterpunching meaning I hate giving an
answer to this because I think it really
is predicated
your partner and then the evolution of
your kids My partner part I really kind
of took care of I mean I was looking for
Lizzy when I found her I locked her up
marry her immediately we were married
within the year of meeting I told her on
our first date that we were getting
married I knew that she was independent
enough and could I intuitively felt that
she could handle the insanity that is me
it's crazy I feel like we're still
dating
because you know I travel so much and
like I'm busy but like it's just over
communication when I see a little screen
I'll cancel a trip I won't say yes you
know I try to hack the kids are a whole
new variable you know now that Mischa's
five and a half I've got to get ready
for they may not be like Lizzy you know
my little Xander might wanna add every
single thing at every moment so I'm
starting to get mentally prepared to
counterpunch their reality kids are
always going to want their parents
around but but what's the hack right
like do I like it's funny I've been
traveling and where I speak now I spoke
in Anaheim and I notice that Disneyland
was right next door so I'm like hmm
maybe I'll do these speaking engagements
because I'll take the kids let them see
what Dad does and then a full day I did
so it's interesting how my brain is
starting to adjust to what's their
reality gonna be like so my answer to
your question is counterpunching what I
mean by that is gross over-communicating
having those conversations with your
spouse or with your partner having those
conversations maybe even at an early age
with your children Shea asks think back
to a time piss someone off how badly did
you piss them off what did you do to
make up for it this is a really
interesting question [ __ ] or not oh
man me too I'm like suffocated by
pissing someone off ah I'll take this
pissing someone off so look I mean the
only time I'm truly ever affected ever
by pissing someone off is when I piss
myself off so it's a little bit of a
wrinkle meaning I am so aggressive to
try not to piss off anyone that the
second I taste in the water that I did I
start hedging like a hog you know like I
started like really did you get that
sonic hedgehog good all right you got it
uh I'm in full apology mode immediately
the only time I
even uncomfortable pissing people off as
onstage
when I'm challenging the audience to the
prequel quo so I'm on a one-to-one basis
I'm crippled by hurting someone's
feelings and the second that I sense it
I start backtracking so the way I answer
the way I fix it is by immediately
taking the the gas off the pedal because
I don't like that feeling I think
there's other ways to manipulate my
point that's the truth I truly think
that I can drive home my point through
honey not vinegar yeah I agree I mean
there's there's no worse feeling than
upsetting someone else and that's it
because I have a very specific image in
my mind when I think of pissing someone
off but I can tell you that living life
or you pander to other people to make
sure you never have enemies or never
have someone dislike you is a very
dangerous game to play and I've always
said with my work that I'd rather if a
hundred people see a movie I make I'd
rather have 50 people love it and fifty
people hate it than have a hundred
people go so it's a fine line in that
idea of pissing someone off can mean so
many different things last time somebody
walked away from me angry I honestly
can't remember but the last time I read
the YouTube comments on any one of my
videos and there were a hundred percent
positive well there was never that last
time was I don't think it's ever
happened yeah I mean what that just made
me think of LinkedIn boy does the
conservative business world hate where
I'm coming from you know it's funny I'm
sure a lot of people are watching right
now and saying what my might living is
being in the minority of my points of
view on the current state of marketing
and all that stuff but I'm with you like
on a one-to-one basis never as little as
possible to the masses no problem and I
think that's an interesting insight yeah
I think so because as a human being the
ambition is never to piss someone else
off or leave someone else upset but as
far as a belief system for surety system
has to be uniquely yours even if that's
a division I will also say I'm in the in
the in the sport sense like in
competition I'm very interested in
pissing people off I'm I'm you know it's
it matters to me a lot like nothing
excites me more than if I know
somebody's upset because I did something
positive from
my team versus theirs I'm it's extremely
interesting to me to piss people off
during the heat of battle because I want
to get them emotional and off their game
yeah yeah all right let's move on
Hobbs asks if you could have a bionic
body part which body part would it be
and what powers would it have the truth
is I do have a bionic body part my right
leg from the knee to the hip from the
hip all the way in is made out of
titanium I didn't know that yeah most
people don't and the superpower that it
gives me yeah I think I can victor up
make this but when I was in the hospital
that leg broken in like it literally 27
places and they were hammer right back
together made out of out of metal the
doctor said to me you know you'll never
run again you'll be like catch up with a
taxicab but you will never run again and
I was 26 years old and that is a tough
thing for a 26 year old to hear
especially someone as physical as I am
so the superpower that it gave me was
prior to that prior to getting my bionic
limb I wasn't much of an athlete or
runner but since getting my metal leg
I've run 22 marathons and for Ironman
triathlons and countless other races and
I'm a much fitter faster person since
getting my bionic leg so it has I do
have a bionic limb and I do have a
superpower I also have a bionic limb
that nope no I don't I really find one
though I was excited to hear what live
where you're gonna go it you know what I
would go with ears I I'm not joking
I'm very intrigued by the notion of like
I love picking up senses right and for
some reason so one of the things that I
think I do extremely well is I that I
really enjoy being able to do and I'd
love to do more of which is why I'm
going with yours is I am often at a
dinner table or at a conference having a
conversation fully in it and capable of
listening to the two or three other side
conversations a matter of fact often
when I talk to a small group of 40 or 50
people I will use side whispering of
what I just said to incorporate into my
talk and then look at the person and
they're always freaked out because I'm
so focused and going here but I heard
them and so I think people don't listen
that's a big thesis of mind it's my
overall social media thesis and so I'm
gonna go with ears I'm just picturing
gear like metal ears responded people
case but one of the things we do on this
show I didn't tell you but I'm sure
you're busy doing your thing is we get
to ask a question of the day of the
vaynernation I know you're not prepped
and so that makes it even more fun for
me but I'm just trying to talk a little
longer to give you a couple seconds you
get to ask them any question you like
we're going to end this show with you
asking the vaynernation vaynernation
please our first ever guest so get into
lurkers is a good time to come out
please ask your questions your bag like
a two-part question if it's already been
asked forgive me but it's really I'm
always curious about but what is your
greatest fear and why is that too
generic that's a no-no that's good I've
never asked that Yeah right so we're
excited thank you my friend is great
this was a lot of fun hope I get invited
back we'll see I don't know what the
rule is on the Schulich Casey that hits
a good point
anything 144 right yeah I could I like
the doubling up what about 720 I don't
think I'm gonna go that long I'm leaving
that for them to say please do it that
long that's me like fishing for
compliments you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them
I'm such a perv I went to such a dark
place go ahead take it you have body
part the truth is I do have a bionic bye
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
ever jab yeah
yeah
jab
yeah yeah